that he was like oh no I'm gonna tell
Mommy I'm like no no no no no no
Iraq immediately
rad
[Music]
so Nick's been consecutively late for
the past two months every [ __ ] day
and so he's finally you're about to
start without him we're supposed to
start at 10. and uh it's 10 19. this is
the this is the lessons we go on
teaching we lock it unlock it unlock it
[ __ ] put it booby traps on this
[ __ ] it's like it's like Home
Alone he's already knocked okay who is
that unlock it
it's Nick just come in then hurry up
we're about to start
disappeared
[Laughter]
circling the toilet bowl does to your
brain hey I can't believe I felt for
that
you gotta go home alone this channel
might be going down but it's going down
in [ __ ] Style baby attitude attitude
error attitude error dude I just got hit
in the face of the spear
we just lived our three ninjas [ __ ]
dreams that was [ __ ] sick spear hit
me in the face
every time you're late you come into
another Home Alone gag yeah
you're the third wet Bandit bro
careful boys we are very careful boys
today Bart take it away so I had
something expect that I experienced for
the first time ever I don't know if you
guys have ever been this irresponsible
but I laughed at other people when they
did it like David saw has done this
before I'm like of course yes [ __ ] can
anybody do this and it actually happened
to me
and I ran out of gas on the freeway
whatever happened to you guys yeah it
has like straight up like you're driving
right yeah I see it's been red for a
while and I'm like
nah I'll make it and then like as you
keep pressing the gas it goes boom and
then you're just pressing the gas you're
like oh [ __ ] this is the moment but was
this in Vegas yeah so what happened was
um I had to pick up Taiko from school
right
already been on red and uh if you guys
know what's been going on with taika
like this motherfucker's been getting
seizures and [ __ ] and he has to take
medication he gets has side effects at
school so like his life isn't going too
good he knows he's been getting in
trouble and he feels bad he wants to be
a good boy so the only thing that's
really going good in his life right now
is basketball practice nice so and his
dad's showing up on time so it was the
day take a guess no so it was the day
that right after school we're going to
basketball practice so when I picked
them up I was like [ __ ] do I got enough
time to go pump gas
or am I going to be late to the only
thing going good in his life so I was
like ah [ __ ] it I just wing it I'm like
hey get in the car and I'm driving I'm
like hell yeah like this is going pretty
good and I'm like uh two exits away from
uh the YMCA he plays basketball at and
I'm like oh [ __ ] I think I'm actually
gonna make it this is [ __ ] dope one
exit away goes and I'm like [ __ ] and I'm
like going like this he's like what
happened Papa
I ran out of gas and then he was like oh
no I'm gonna tell Mommy I'm like
a rat why immediately wraps you up what
a rat no no no no don't wait don't worry
we're gonna get there and so I was
trying to see if I'm gonna be able to
just [ __ ] Coast until I get there
yeah put a neutral I'm just going going
I'm okay cool I think I'm gonna make it
and then I see the exit and has a slight
uphill
no no no no no no no so it slows down my
momentum and I see myself going from
like like 60 to 50 to 40 to 30. I make
it over the hill I'm like okay good good
like a roller coaster like this
I exit the freeway like this and then I
turn and it's at like 2015 10. I'm like
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] is there a gas station no
there's no gas station no and that's
what I'm like what the [ __ ] am I gonna
do just [ __ ] park the car in the
middle of the street I was like no I
can't do that so I pull into the mall
that's like so here's a mall the YMCA is
right here I pull into the entrance and
the mall is [ __ ] stupid ass design
Mall the entrance
so I [ __ ] pulling this [ __ ] stupid
ass mall we slow down he goes oh no papa
what are you gonna do and I was like I
put the E-brake on I put on a park I'm
like [ __ ] I was like you don't need the
e-brake by the way you don't have any
gas I was like just oh I don't want to
roll away I was like just start changing
right rolling away sounds like good idea
at this point I was like just start
changing right now he was like what do
you mean to change right now I was like
we're going to basketball practice we're
gonna [ __ ] run across the street
we're gonna go to basketball practice
he's like all right and then now he
thinks it's an adventure so it's
actually fun from so he's not putting on
his clothes and then I'm like [ __ ] what
do I do what do I do I call Triple A and
I couldn't like oh it's so annoying it's
annoying now you gotta do some [ __ ]
[ __ ] website and then my AAA is like
registered in California so it's not
registered why like my ZIP code isn't my
old California ZIP code uh like it
wasn't making any sense it makes sense
for their you know drivers but I thought
it was supposed to be an emergency
they're all [ __ ] in California like
where where's your car I didn't know AAA
does Nevada well I don't know oh okay so
anyways I I type I type it in the
[ __ ] it says they're gonna come
in like over an hour I'm like this is
[ __ ] [ __ ] so I just took a piece
of paper I wrote emergency
um if you need me to move this car
um text this number put that on the
dashboard please bring gas
I see a [ __ ] security guard come by
with one of those golf carts I'm like
perfect I'm like hello hello I'm like
I'm literally blocking traffic so if you
can help me this will help you where
people won't will be able to get into
the mall and he goes I'll see what I can
do he drives off and he just he doesn't
come back I'm like he doesn't come back
I'm like this [ __ ] so I'm like
[ __ ] it I'm gonna hit tiger we're gonna
just run across the street I'm gonna
hold my hand so we'll just start running
and it's probably a good
15 minute non-stop run because you know
malls are big right it's like even
though you can see it you're running
across the parking lot and then you got
to run across another parking lot and
it's like so we run run and we finally
make it I get them there oh my God hey
cool good and then now the tough part is
like Geo's always on my case of driving
in the red it's like why the [ __ ] are
you always in the red that's the worst I
know I hate it when the women are right
so I text her I was like hey are you
busy
[Laughter]
nothing
right away what
what I mean you gotta promise me you
can't get mad
and she goes I'm mad already
[Music]
so you know how you're always getting on
me about driving the red huh it's a
funny thing
can you come to his practice and watch
him so I can go to my car and get the
gas filled she's like what the [ __ ] you
drove on red and I was like yeah and
finally and it went out and so she ended
up coming and then I was able to go but
right when I got there Triple A got
there too so it was good they had like
the little mobile gas tank that's so
funny oh you actually were able to
contact them yeah it was one of those
where it showed like they were gonna
take like an hour or two and they just
show up and then randomly it goes we'll
be there in five minutes
but I just started sprinting
uh back there and good thing no one
stole my car or nothing it was just left
just the way maybe someone tried you
left the keys in there yeah how would
how would they steal your car you left
the emergency brakes on that's true okay
but yeah I never thought this would ever
happen and taka got his [ __ ] free
throws in so that was cool that's sick
but I never ever ran out of gas floor
dude only Bart is like so I'm running
out of gas I'm like oh [ __ ] there's no
gas so then I'm like you know I drive
for like a couple more miles and then I
pulled over and I'm like oh that's a
good spot right there I'll stop at that
mall right there I go up this hill to go
into this mall and then I park
I'm like dude that is not my running out
of gas story at all what are you doing I
was [ __ ] running out of gas I used to
have this truck and it used to have uh
well towards the end of its life with me
the gauge was not reporting correctly so
it said I had a quarter tank but then
I'm like it's like okay and I'm like oh
[ __ ] I'm [ __ ] right or if you're on an
incline and the gases yeah exactly yeah
so then I was just like you know in stop
start La [ __ ] [ __ ] show traffic yeah
what are you gonna do so I all I could
do was barely it's like it's like you
it's like you know how you have an
intention of moving over but you have no
momentum yeah so like just my wheels
you're just crooked I'm in the lane but
my wheels go like that I'm like well
hopefully people get the idea they can
see you tried yeah yeah I'll try it okay
you gotta use the old school hand
signals yeah you gotta remember them all
right so then yeah so then I was I you
know I was in the middle of the [ __ ]
road and then I'm just like oh [ __ ] well
I I put the emergency lights on and then
I was waiting there maybe somebody could
help me push it or whatever but it's a
[ __ ] big truck dude like it wasn't
that thing wasn't going anywhere
I remember back in the day everyone used
to like lose gas at an intersection and
you would see all these people come out
as a community to push that man into the
gas station yeah love that I was
actually gonna risk it when I was in the
mall oh dude I'm pretty strong probably
push this [ __ ] I was like what
if I put it in neutral run out of the
car real quick
we're all inclined and there's a
five-year-old in this [ __ ] yeah
if I just get [ __ ] squished I get
pushed into the back into the street I'm
gonna be so [ __ ] I was like well you
should have had is taika control the
wheel and then
what the [ __ ] are you [ __ ] training
all day for if you can't push your car
up a hill man I could try later at lunch
yeah let's try it let's try it let's do
an experiment JK experiment I never
would take you for a guy that wouldn't
fill up his gas tank I feel like I do
fill it up to the top every single time
I wouldn't take you as a guy who would
like put your Like Son rehearsal and
life in danger you know he made it to
basketball practice dude imagine if this
dude only fills up quarter tank at a
time no no no
way sort of all the way every single
time dude I actually just had an
incident driving in Vegas when I thought
of Nick immediately it was during
Thanksgiving weeks it was like [ __ ]
hectic I got I was hosting Thanksgiving
for the first time so I have to get a
bunch of [ __ ] and I'm sitting there and
there's ladies in front of me and when
people don't just fill out the space in
front of them like if I'm sitting at a
light or something and I see somebody's
got like nine car lengths in front of
them they're just [ __ ] sitting there
I'm like I want you to die I [ __ ]
hate you I did so so there's this lady
who's like in front of me and then I see
there's a there's a there's someone
parked and there's like so many car
links and I'm like what the [ __ ] is with
this lady in front of me like this this
lady isn't like what are we doing here
[ __ ] what are we doing here like let's
[ __ ] get around this [ __ ] that's
the right answer and then she she's like
gesturing and [ __ ] and I'm like yeah
you're a [ __ ] idiot
I'm like yo how do I drive a car I don't
[ __ ] know you know I'm like really
[ __ ] having it right and then um so
she finally there's like a break in the
in the traffic enough where she like can
scoot over and I'm like I finally see a
[ __ ] and then I pull up and see the
emergency lights of the person in front
of her and I'm like
I'm a [ __ ] dick that made you think
of me
I thought about being an [ __ ] in
traffic which is what our thing is yeah
but then like you know immediately
karmically smacked that happens to me
that's that that happens I had that
happen and then the guy that I rolled up
to he was like this
oh he passed out yeah he was knocked out
so I was like oh [ __ ] it I'm not gonna
wake him up I'm busy
years ago I told you I think but I saw a
car just completely flipped over like in
the middle it was a rainstorm in in L.A
and I saw a car completely flipped over
and there's a guy just standing outside
of it
oh I caught hands on his head just dazed
yeah and he was drunk as [ __ ] a skunk
Wow have you guys ever ran out of gas I
guess more responsible than that oh I
have but that's because my fuel line uh
burst oh oh [ __ ] that sucked because did
someone try to assassinate you or
something no it's just my because my
van's so freaking old and I I just
filled it up with like because my van
takes 125 bucks to fill like even in
past prices like Obama prices what about
now like 200 the pump stops because it
doesn't go past a certain amount so then
like inquiry I just filled it up and
then I started driving and then I
noticed my thing was I was like the [ __ ]
and then I looked and I had a big ass
trail of like gas because my my lights
went and and then again that was La it
was in Hollywood like right by the
church next to the bowl and I had to
push it myself nobody helped me oh no no
it's that kind of town baby nobody gives
a [ __ ] about you I think the closest I
was at was like I wasn't noticing my my
gas tank and then um I went to the top
of the mountains right here and then
that's when it turned the yellow light
came on and I was like oh [ __ ] but then
because I was uphill I just put it in
neutral and rolled all the way down and
then used the gas to get to yeah that's
so good when that happens yeah I know I
got lucky because imagine if I was at
the bottom of the mountain
and then by the time I got to the top
I'm done what happened to you today you
said you almost crashed yeah some dude
almost hit me and I swerved and my car
started hydroplaning oh [ __ ] on the
freeway yeah dude like hopping on the
tent and that's why you're late again
well I was late for other reasons
yeah what's tomorrow's excuse me I was
late for other reasons it rains that's
pretty good though but also too though
people were driving like such total
[ __ ] today like people were all day
or every day
started raining right oh yeah so then
people are and I know there's like such
a cliche like La thing like people
really don't know how to [ __ ] drive
but they really [ __ ] oh it's true
it's because they stay driving like it's
dry when it's raining oh bro so
everyone's going [ __ ] 80 90
hydroplaning and that's like half of
them and then the other half is going 20
miles an hour like what's coming out of
the sky what the [ __ ] what do we do yeah
they're like like this like it's a
[ __ ] thunderstorm and it's like
sprinkling coats already yeah but dude
I've been bitching forever but a later
hours but then I moved to Vegas and
everyone drives slow as [ __ ] in Vegas
they're so slow it's like I'm back in
Santa Barbara where Nikki's parents are
I'm always bitching about Santa Barbara
drivers I think I just hate drivers
everywhere
like self-govern on lost so I remember
driving and I'm like why the [ __ ] is
everyone slowing down and it's because
it's a school zone there's no kids
around and I'm like you guys really slow
to 25 when no cops around wow because in
L.A no one gives a [ __ ] you could be
next to like Alhambra high school if
there's no kids out they're going like
70 miles an hour I'm like this is crazy
I'm like everyone actually follows the
rules I'm like all right I got to try to
follow the rules too yeah you can you
can weave past the crossing guard yeah
I'm like what the [ __ ] real slow yeah
everyone just slows down randomly and
then they pick back up and I'm like oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] you guys actually follow the
rules huh kind of reminds me of Hawaii
how people drive in Hawaii yeah they
they did a study that Aloha Spirit
causes more accidents I feel like it's
kind of nice for a change like if
everyone's driving slow then I'm like
all right I could drive no dude but in
Hawaii it's like if you're like trying
to if you're a tourist and you're just
driving around and you happen to be slow
the [ __ ] locals are like on your ass
dude they're like you just gotta read
the room though like wherever you're at
read the lane I mean like if you know
what I do I drive for two people so if
I'm if I hit like a [ __ ] stop sign
and the [ __ ] person in front of me
stops too long but you stop for me too
so if they go I just go with them I do
oh that's that's tight that's really
dangerous
when there's a merge lane yeah and I can
just shove my [ __ ] ass out here so
all these [ __ ] can't uh
I'm imagining you doing that in your old
Mini Cooper hey it was it was it was red
too so it's like a stop sign dude you
know what gets me hard harder than
anything is when I'm trying to get into
a lane and there's two cars it's a
perfect little sandwich right there's a
car in front I'm in the middle and
they're behind
and they have their blinkers on I have
my blinkers on I'm trying to get in
their Lane they're trying to get in my
lane and we merge perfectly oh I'm just
oh
get the [ __ ] a Top Gun bro I'm like
what are we you were smarter yeah you
were smart enough to get what I was
doing it's just time the [ __ ]
are going like this I'm like perfect I'm
gonna go and you're like yeah go on my
lane and they're like no no yeah exactly
I'm like you stupid [ __ ] this could have
been So Graceful now I'm thinking I'm
fighting you but I'm not I'm letting you
get ahead of me I wanna I wanna follow
them and be like you guys want to start
a business together
okay you guys want to do something like
we have good sitters yeah like we get it
we didn't even look at each other group
Minds yeah you want come on Jakey
it's the best dude it's the best it gets
me so excited I love it I'm a big fan of
that wait but then the opposite makes me
want to blow my brains out it just makes
me want to crash my car into the water I
think it's because I think I get so
stressed in traffic because we're all
just right there on the edge of death
100 and people don't think about that
[ __ ] I know I do I'm terrified that's
very extreme like it is true though like
if one little [ __ ] up can change your
whole life in someone else's life
forever don't finish somebody at the
right speed and it's over imagine like
that but on a bike it's like times 100.
that's why I don't I don't [ __ ] with
bikes bro I don't do that either when
you brought the Vespa over here I was
like I'm good in the parking lot when I
see the bikes do you guys do the [ __ ]
I move over I always move over and
though I always do that yeah let's throw
on a bike
bikers this morning boys
flashing dude that's why he's late yeah
and then I pull in front of him and I
hit my my windshield wiper cleaners so
the water gets all over I love that
oh that actually that gets me hard did
you say there was like a reason you were
late like a bad thing happened oh no I
was late because my client just wouldn't
shut up dude and I'm like hey man I
gotta go wrap it up dude no no it's okay
but you know I was on time dude 10 20.
we're good bro first shot you get Spears
in your face how'd you like our trap
what are your thoughts honestly I was
like I got hit in the face of the spirit
and I was like yeah I deserve that yeah
she was like dude lock the door at 10
15. lock the door 10 15 we locked the
door now if any of us are late we're
gonna be standing at the other side like
you're on the edge dude yeah usually
I'll say this when Steve's on the call
sheet I'm like I have a little bit of a
buffer hey I say that about you really
yeah I'm like oh [ __ ] Nick's coming so
but you've been you've been beating me
out way more
hey guess what tomorrow I'm about to be
here [ __ ] 10 o'clock dude
wow that's like that's on time yeah
right on the call sheet made it sound
like it was gonna be early all right you
know what I'll be here earlier if you
want to go I'm not the guy to do it
I'll be here pointlessly at [ __ ] 7
30. that's a [ __ ] I will okay all
right now we have a challenge dude I'll
be your [ __ ] I finished tomorrow at
nine o'clock I'll be here [ __ ] I'm
here earlier tomorrow cool but today was
the day out of all the days to actually
be on time that's true I'm on fault but
we're skipping lunch dude it gives a
[ __ ] about lunch
honestly our lunch is too long sometimes
it's an hour
it's great I've appreciate you guys it's
like a unionized lunch but it's also
like we gotta you know that's because
Bart needed to nap uh that's true that's
true but it used to be two hours but I
think oh okay on certain days
so okay when Bart wasn't here we powered
right through that [ __ ] skip the walk
one day what day was it we would finish
out we would be we would start late and
finish at five we were done at 3 15.
anyway let's try to increase the
lifespans around here
this is the Siesta that we need dude I
appreciate it that's cool though you
know other jobs don't give you siestas
that's the best thing about this place
we're bitching about how long lunch is
yeah yeah dude and it's like we get to
[ __ ] sit behind the camera and just
talk some [ __ ] you know it's a little
bit fun to come in late and wonder what
the Trap is though isn't it yeah
honestly I do I do feel bad I was like
I'm sorry I apologize that's why I'm
like I accept it fully it was a great
video a great moment it makes a better
video we're also a few minutes over we
can end this anytime